it was an act of sabotage on an epic
scale just over a month ago someone blew
up the Nordstrom pipelines which bring
gas from Russia to Europe
those responsible haven't been
officially identified but today Russia
named its new Prime Suspect accusing the
UK of being behind the attack
according to available information
representatives of this unit of the
British Navy took part in the planning
backup and carrying out of this
terrorist attack in the Baltic Sea on
September the 26th of this year to blow
up the nordstream 1 and Nordstrom 2 gas
pipelines
without providing evidence moscow's
claimed the same British Specialists
helped Ukraine carry out a drone strike
on its Black Sea Fleet on Saturday
footage shared by Ukrainian media
purports to show a warship Under Fire in
Sebastopol Sky News has been unable to
verify the pictures but previously the
Kremlin accused the U.S of targeting
nordstream before turning on the UK
the ministry of Defense has been damning
in its rebuttal
to detract from their disastrous
handling of the illegal invasion of
Ukraine the Russian Ministry of defense
is resorting to peddling false claims of
an epic scale a spokesperson said in a
statement this invented story says more
about arguments going on inside the
Russian government than it does about
the West
and for many Russia not Britain Remains
the most likely culprit since the
invasion of Ukraine it's been criticized
for weaponizing energy slashing gas
deliveries to Europe and benefiting from
rising prices the most likely culprit
behind the attacks is the only country
that has got something to gain from this
and that's Russia you know they are
continuing their economic war against
the West against the EU this is the eu's
main gas supply or Wars and they're
doing the same with grain out of the
Ukrainian Southern Odessa ports and
elsewhere this is taking the Ukraine
conflict and turning it into a global
conflict with a global impact and that
impact is still being felt a month after
the nordstream attacks fear and
suspicion continue to spread Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Germany